this is jaco podcast number 112 with
echo Charles and me jakka willing
good evening echo good evening I had a
friend and someday when I can I will
tell you all about him
but until then for now I will say that I
could not have asked for a better friend
did he have faults sure
don't we all now most of his faults
weren't really that big of a deal but
they were raw raw because he admitted to
them all openly and directly and naively
to be honest in a sort of pointed and
heavy-handed self critique he would bear
his weaknesses to the world and to me
and to himself and he would speak to me
as if I had no faults and I would try to
explain otherwise but he wouldn't listen
he would only judge himself I'm too
emotional he would say not really I'd
tell him I don't know how to talk to
people right
sure you do let's say I make the same
mistakes over and over and over again he
would say we all do I would tell him I
was better than him at some things we
both knew that there were other things
he was better at than me but he always
downplayed those things and we both knew
that too when we were overseas in a bad
place in a wretched place he never
complained and I gave him every reason
to I put him in the worst locations with
the greatest possible chances for
failure and the highest probability for
fire and theory and blood and death
but despite the enemy than the heat and
the living conditions and the fear and
the wounded men and the screams and the
misery that was all around he did not
complain it seemed at times that God
himself was trying to test the limits of
my friend and it seemed like sooner or
later the bullets or the bombs would
find him but through some
incomprehensible miracle he survived
through that deployment
now I make no claim whatsoever to
understand why things in life unfold the
way they do in fact I must say that many
of the things I've seen in the world
make no sense to me at all sometimes
it's just utter confusion no rhyme no
reason some of the things that I've seen
have left me downright disgusted jaded
repulsed sickened by mankind and the
awful and reprehensible things we are
capable of but there's another side to
that there's another side and there are
other people who do their best to redeem
all the evil our souls are capable of my
friend was one of those people after
deploying with me and surviving that
bloody and violent battlefield my friend
like most of the guys in my old job he
volunteered to deploy again I fought and
I told him prematurely and incorrectly
that the enemy was done I told him that
the war was all but over I told him just
do the deployment and sit tight over
there and play the game and in a few
months we'll be back and we can go
surfing and we can play guitar and we
can tell stories and we can cook steaks
and we can serve some more I told him we
could carry on when he got home
that was the plan it was a good plan
but the enemy gets a vote
and there was intense violence during
that deployment for him as well it was
similar to what we had experienced
together overseas an aggressive enemy
hell-bent on killing Americans mixed in
an urban environment with a terrified
local populace he told me that the enemy
he was now facing wasn't as tactically
skilled as the enemy we had faced but he
said that they were braver and more
determined that seemed to concern him a
bit more he seemed to feel the odds were
that he would die he sent me his last
will and testament he was not morose
about it just stating the facts it's bad
over here the enemy is aggressive
casualty rates are very high the enemy
has new weapons that are extremely
capable
it didn't look good I waited I waited
the long and completely powerless wait
one known mostly by mothers and fathers
and wives and children that are old
enough to understand but a weight also
made by the brothers at home that know
the risk all too well it was a long wait
at my friends and memorial service his
brother told a story my friend had
talked to his brother on the phone while
my friend was on deployment and my
friend had explained to his brother in
no uncertain terms the situation that my
friend was in the enemy was extremely
hostile the battlefield was chaotic the
attacks were frequent and furious it was
violence that my friend had not
experienced before this was war
unleashed and it seemed to be heading to
an inescapable conclusion and my
friend's brother sent this even through
the phone even thousands of miles away
as his brother he sensed the darkness
and the overwhelming finality of the
situation and he said to my friend do
you need anything from me how can I help
is there anything that I can do and my
friend was quiet for a moment and then
my friend made one simple request
he said pray for my men now I want you
to think about that I want you to think
about that level of selflessness that
level of faith and of commitment and of
care for others that dedication in the
face of fear and violence and death to
at that moment put others before
yourself
to do good to be a relic and strong and
brave and yet at the same time to be
humble and to be willing to sacrifice
everything for your friends that's a man
and I couldn't have asked for a better
friend
the world can be a horrible place it's
filled with violence and treachery and
sometimes it seems that the legions of
demonic powers have the upper hand in
the battle between good and evil and it
can seem that all might be lost and then
we remember we see the light and for me
the light comes from the example of
others in this case another person
another human being my friend who
despite all the powers of darkness stood
up and rejected all that wickedness and
proved that there is hope and there is a
path to light and we can get on that
path if we choose to do so like my
friend did
and that's life at least as far as I can
unravel the mystery that's what I see we
are here and the best thing we can do is
stand against the darkness and try to
spread light in the world but that can
be a very hard thing to do because life
is not easy in fact it is said and there
are very few that would deny that life
itself is suffering but there is a way
and there is a path
and today I have someone on the podcast
for a second time that I think can help
guide us down that path away from
darkness and toward the light dr. Jordan
B Peterson welcome back to the podcasts
for a second time thanks charlie
you were on podcast number 98 last time
and if anyone wants to stop right now go
and listen to 98 if you haven't listened
to it yet and that's a good place to
start learning about you and then you
could also just google Jordan Peterson
and go from there because there's
thousands you think there's thousands of
hours of you of content of you on
YouTube yeah there's there's probably
horrible as it is to contemplate yeah
there probably is I mean I've
contributed about 500 hours probably of
lectures and so on but people have been
cutting it up and right there's all the
podcasts and YouTube videos that other
people have made and I think I look the
other day because people keep chopping
up the lectures and the intros and
making little videos and my son and I
tried to estimate it last week it looked
like 4,000 people had made videos last
week in the bank in one week yeah it's
really yeah it's crazy it's it really is
okay so you've got a new book out and
the book is called twelve twelve rules
for life an antidote to chaos and you
know one of the key points in the book
is life is suffering right and clearly I
think a the malevolence because it's not
enough you know
we do a little bonus on yeah yeah yeah
so you need to inflict it yeah you know
obviously my old line of work we got to
see that and we got to see it all the
time two things number one where does
that come from and I you don't need to
spend a bunch of time on that because
you've talked about that so much but
more important to me what happens when
people miss that point well that the
suffering seems to be built-in in some
sense and and it's a very difficult
thing to understand fully because the
fundamental question is does being
justify suffering it's something like
that and and there's this old idea I
read this it was a Jewish idea it's it's
kind of a riddle and so it's a riddle
about the nature of God and so the
riddle runs what does a being who's
omniscient omnipotent and omnipresent so
those are the three classical attributes
of God lack thank well that's nothing
obviously it's no limitation and so and
so that was the explanation for why God
created everything but more particularly
why God created man it's that there's
something about limitation that adds to
completeness maybe because it provides
something to struggle against it's
something like that and in the book and
12 rules for life I talked about what
happens just happened to Superman in the
1980s it's like Superman got so powerful
that you could bounce hydrogen bombs off
his chest you know and he could move
planets it's like and then he got boring
at the same time because what are you
what are you gonna do to him nothing is
like he he can just solve every problem
instantly well there's no story there
and you might say well who cares if
there's a story and and that's a
reasonable objection maybe there should
just be no story at all right that's the
Memphis to feely an objection to life
there should be no story at all but
maybe that's not the right answer maybe
it's better to have being even if it
requires limitation even if the
limitation necessitates suffering even
if the limitation and the suffering
necessitate evil now
a separate issue perhaps there's a way
of maneuvering through that a pathway
that makes that all not only acceptable
let's say at least acceptable that would
be a good start
but but fully justifiable something that
you would voluntarily accept if you have
the opportunity
Nietzsche Nietzsche sort of caught on to
that in some sense with his idea of the
eternal return he said you should try to
live each moment of your life so that if
you had to live that moment recurring
for eternity that you would find that
desirable it's like it's a high standard
man so but but but there's a very
interesting point there which is that
maybe you can say that despite the
suffering and malevolence this is worth
it and I think people have experiences
like that in their life you know and you
can have more experiences if you live
your life I would say according if
you're on the proper path then maybe
your life can consist of almost nothing
but experiences like that now you know I
say that knowing full well that people
get cut off at the knees and that life
can be very arbitrary and hard and that
everyone is is prone to the the negative
consequences of deceit and betrayal all
of those things I mean the book the book
twelve rules for life in some sense is a
very dark book but it's not exactly
because the darker the darkness the
brighter the light appears it's
something like that and you know you say
well no life's not so bad you can be
happy and I think no life really is bad
it's really bad and no matter how bad
you think it is it's actually worse than
that you can't really get to the bottom
of how terrible things can get you know
people who have post-traumatic stress
disorder know that you know they've hit
something so bad that they cannot live
with it they have no idea how to live
with it and it hurts them not just
psychologically but physiologically as
well it's very difficult to recover so
they have a sense of how bad it can be
and then they can hardly live with it
but I would say despite that and I would
say also that this is the central idea
in the in twelve rules for life is that
despite that bottomless horror in some
sense there is a way of being that's
powerful enough to
both transcend and justify that in some
sense and that has to do with with with
the decision to act as if it would be
better if things were better that's the
first thing and you think well that's
easy I'd like things to be better it's
no no wait a second
there's hatred in your heart and there's
resentment in your soul and there's
bitterness at your position in the world
and there's the sense that you're a
victim and there's the anger that goes
along with that and the desire to hurt
like you have all of that and maybe you
have it in spades maybe it's mostly what
you are and because of that you do not
want things to be better you want to
spread some misery out of spite and
that's what chapter six is about right
and put your house in perfect order
before you criticize the world it's
about people like the Columbine High
School shooters and exactly what they
were motivated by because I understand
what they were motivated by and so ii
wish that things were better means that
you have to make a real decision that
despite all the flaws of existence the
suffering and the malevolence that it's
best not to become embittered by that
and to work for the betterment of
everyone you for sure your family for
sure your community but perhaps even
your enemies you know if you have any
sense
you wish your enemies well that doesn't
mean you wish them victory it doesn't
mean you don't think they're wrong none
of that it means that it would be better
if the world was set up so that they
didn't have to suffer miserably and
futilely and evilly as well that would
be better and so then you can aim at
that now and the best way to aim at that
is well first of all they aim at it to
actually sort yourself out and think
okay well if I could have things the way
I wanted them to be that's what I would
want right and that takes a lot of
psychological organization before you
can state that without without what
would you say without holding anything
back you know because there's that part
of you that bitter part that wants
vengeance and wants and wants to wreak
havoc that's there it's hard to
constrain that and then
while the other part along with this as
well as aiming at the highest good
that's attainable let's say is to also
decide that you're going to speak the
truth in that endeavor and to risk that
you know and there's that and because I
think those are the things that that
help you aren't yourself properly that's
the message of the Sermon on the Mount
by the way which is aim at the highest
good that you can conceive of and act
and tell the truth in that pursuit right
the the other element there is to focus
on the day once you've once you've
aligned yourself with the heavenly star
right aim high and then focus on the day
that's very good advice because it also
imbues everything you do in your daily
life with significance as to why am I
doing this to avoid hell that's a good
one let's start with that's like to
avoid hell and if you have any
imagination at all if you lived in the
world at all if you're not naive you
know what that means it's not just the
hell that you encounter it's the hell
that you foolishly produce around
yourself and are then responsible for
that's a perfectly good sort of hell so
you want to avoid that for sure and
maybe you want to dare risking making
things better it's like that imbue your
life with significance and that
significance you know one of the things
I've discovered learned I would say over
the last 25 years is that there's always
been a mythological idea or an idea in
literature and philosophy that there was
a Shining Path you know that you could
walk down and modern cynical people
believe that that sort of meaning the
meaning that would be obtained by
walking on that path is somehow illusory
or arbitrary and I don't think there's
any evidence whatsoever that that's true
I think that sense of meaningful
engagement that what is revealed to you
when you're in the right place at the
right time doing the right thing that
sense of deep engagement that loss of
self-consciousness that feeling that
things are worthwhile that deep-seated
feeling that things are worthwhile
that's the most real thing I think I
think the neurobiological evidence
suggests that I really do believe that
and so we're in a fortunate time in some
sense but
as we can look at those old metaphorical
ideas of the of The Shining Path let's
say that the golden path forward and we
can say yeah that's actually real that's
real and that's something and then
that's so what's what's so cool about
that in my estimation is that and this
is why twelve rules for life is actually
an optimistic book is like the darkness
is real but the light is stronger it's
like wow could that be true could that
possibly be true I think it's true so
that's a good thing to know man that
that might be true in and you know the
when I was talking about my friend in
the beginning in this podcast that's
that's why I was talking about it
because it was a guy who had every
reason to be to be negative and to be
dark and to look at the world and just
say this is hell it's not worth it but
instead what he really did was want to
take care of his of his friends I talked
about a woman in my book is that someone
I met as a client when I was just
beginning my psychotherapeutic practice
and she just blew me away I've never
forgotten her so she was she had a
horrible life
she was unattractive uneducated no
career unemployed so shy you can't even
imagine it like you've met someone shy
and anxious it's like they weren't in
the same universe as this woman she was
so shy that she couldn't walk up to
people without looking at the ground
hunching over and shielding her eyes so
that's how she approached people on the
street and and she she looked like a
homeless person as well and so and she
came to the behavior therapy unit that I
was working at and hypothetically for
treatment and so what we started doing
was seeing if we could get her to stand
up a bit and look people in the eye more
normally so that people wouldn't respond
to her as if she was so peculiar you
know so we were trying to just to change
her behavior but I started talking to
her and well she told me a little bit
about her life it's like she lived it
better she lived where she lived her
mother was I think she lived with her
aunt who was like a violent
schizophrenic alcoholic who had
religious delusions and constantly
accused her of being
by the devil and she had a really
violent and abusive alcoholic boyfriend
who used to mistreat this woman so that
was like home life hey it's like yeah
and she had been an inpatient in this
hospital that Douglass hospital and that
was in the 1980s and the Douglass
hospital was a huge hospital about the
size of a university campus and it had
had a lot of inpatients but they were
all let out on the streets when
medication became widely available and
when deinstitutionalization was the norm
but there was a subset of them who
couldn't be deinstitutionalized and
these were people that you can hardly
imagine so I used to go in the
underground corridors in the Douglass
hospital because it's very cold in
Montreal so their underground corridors
collecting the buildings and down there
there would be vending machines and
places for people to sit and it was like
walking through Dante's Inferno because
these were people who were so damaged
you know they've been in a psychiatric
institution for maybe two or three
decades they could not be released no
matter what even though that's what the
hospital was trying to do and so it was
like Diane Arbus used to go across the
United States and photograph strange
people and she has a whole collection of
her photographs they're quite arresting
and shocking and it was like walking
through Diane Arbus universe you know
and so those were the inpatients and she
had been an inpatient from time to time
but was well enough so she could also go
out and it turned out she didn't
actually want treatment she had this dog
she used to take it for walks and so
that was her source of enjoyment right
and she thought I really like this dog
and I really like taking it for walks
and maybe I could go to the Douglass
hospital and find one of these
inpatients and take him out for a walk
maybe that would be a good thing for him
and so the reason she had come to the
behavior therapy clinic wasn't to treat
all of her problems in life this woman
had problems man everything about her
life was a problem and in ways that like
a normal person just cannot begin to
understand you know unless they're in
one of those situations in their life
where everything is collapsing around
them and what she did what she decided
was well there's someone worse off that
me than me that I could help it's like
she just absolutely blew me away
you know this poor woman she have
nothing going for her while it gets
she did a because she had this nobility
of spirit that was absolutely
indomitable it just I never forgot that
it just though she shall lead her into
her situation in a way if she's so noble
and she wants to help her her aunt
that's all crazy and good no no bad she
wants to help prop up her boyfriend
that's violent no I don't think so I
don't think she wanted any of that she
was just one of these people it's like
you know you can put someone in this
situation that's so dire that that
there's virtually no escape from it like
I've seen people in my clinical practice
for whom things around things around
them have collapsed so badly that
there's just no fixing it there's you
fix one thing and two other things break
and then you fix those and three other
things break there's just no bottom and
those are often families that have had
multi-generational problems deeply
rooted the whole community is
pathologized the entire family structure
is demolished there people don't have
any marketable skills and they haven't
for generations the whole situation is
complicated by drug and alcohol abuse
and and and heavily biologically
influenced insanity of one form or
another usually conjoined with
relatively low cognitive ability it's
just it's just hell no matter which way
you turn in I didn't see her as a
contributor to that I mean I'm sure she
made her mistakes like everyone else but
she was she certainly wasn't playing
martyr or victim she didn't come into
the to the clinic to complain to begin
with just like she was just telling me
these were the situation that she lived
in she wasn't that isn't what she was
there for it's just that we thought she
had come for treatment so we were doing
the background analysis you know an
intake interview and found out all these
things it's like any one of those
problems is enough to bring most
people's lives to a shuddering halt and
yet that was her vision so the reason
she had come to the hospital and she
didn't just come to the behavior therapy
clinic she had gone around pestering
administrators in the hospital to let
her take the long term inmates out for a
walk now they wouldn't do it for you
know for all sorts of reasons but that
didn't stop her from thinking it was a
good idea and it actually was a good
idea this was a practical idea like she
could have taken people out on the
ground
because the grounds were huge and walked
them with the dog and it would have been
fine was there such a thing as pet
therapy in 1985 exactly but she had
enough wherewithal to notice that well
that she liked the dog and the dog liked
her and that was a good thing right
there little bit of love in the world
there and that there was nothing wrong
with taking the dog for a walk and that
was kind of harmless and why not have
someone along they made her feel good
she thought well maybe it'll make me
feel exactly so like Petey just got to
shake your head well that's when I
really learned to begin with deeply that
there's no correlation between
intelligence and wisdom and then that's
actually the case technically like if
you're smart you can just be like you
can be you can be smart and good but you
could be smart and bad yeah that's what
we used to say okay so we'd get these
guys coming in the SEAL Teams that would
be for a while we were recruiting just
the for the officer candidates really
nice guys that were you know they went
to Ivy League schools and they were off
the charts and 1,600 on their SATs and
then they were the captain of this and
when they were just these really high
achievers and we found that not all of
them but certainly some of them couldn't
really function in the desert as a
leader in the job because they just
didn't have the I guess the wisdom to
pull it off but they couldn't make the
personal connections they couldn't
develop a relationship leadership is a
complicated thing and it doesn't boil
down just to intelligence yeah and I
want to make it sound like none of them
work aside from work obviously
outstanding writing credits leaders but
there are some of them that would be the
same kind of recruit but they just
wanted missing whatever piece that was
well intelligence and character are
definitely not the same thing they're
not the same thing I mean all things
considered if you're going to pick one
of two leaders if I would pick the
smarter leader over the duller leader if
all other things were equal
you know because well because someone
who's more intelligent can strategize
more rapidly and can handle more
variables right yeah and perhaps can
even handle well it can handle a more
rapid rate of transformation as well and
sometimes that's actually crucial but
character and intelligence are are
they're clearly not the same thing and
characters actually well I don't think
anything Trump's character that's that
character is everything
so you know it's interesting that you
with this this woman that you talked
about in the beginning you talked about
how she's you know she's crouched down
and she's looking down at the ground and
all that so it's interesting in your
rules obviously the first the first rule
is to stand up straight with your
shoulders back right well when you get
for lack of a better word indoctrinated
in fact there is no better word when you
get indoctrinated into the military
that's exactly what's happening and
guess what you get taught one of the
first things that you get taught is how
to stand how to stand properly and you
know what they tell you chin up chest
out shoulders back
they make you stand like that there's no
coincidence to that is that it's a you
could say it's a dominant stance but
that's not the right way of thinking
about it although it is a dominant
stance the reason to adopt it is not
because it's a dominant stance
it's a confident stance and confidence
tends to make you dominant at least in
in hierarchies that are functioning
properly because you want there are
hierarchies which is what I outlined in
Chapter one I say though hierarchies are
old they're not socio-cultural
constructions
they're not a secondary consequence of
capitalism and the free mark all of that
is absolute nonsense it couldn't be more
wrong and as an indication of that I
point out that lobsters whom we diverged
from on the evolutionary front a third
of a billion years ago have hierarchies
right and that the neurochemical systems
the neural neurological systems that
lobsters have runoff that mediate their
hierarchical status run on the same
chemical that the neurological systems
that we use to mediate hierarchy run on
so that's just absolutely mind-boggling
but lobster like a victorious lobster
stretches out and adopts a more dominant
pose because his serotonin levels go up
as he becomes more and more victorious
and that governs posture well and so to
stand up straight with your shoulders
back is to open yourself up to the world
you're not an if you're not in the
defensive Crouch of a prey animal
technically speaking and that is the
circuitry that's governing posture its
prey vs. predator or something like that
and it to stand up like that is to
expose your yourself to the world but in
a bring it on sort of manner not not
precisely combative but let's say
courageous and your posture announces
that and it doesn't just announce that
to other people it announces that to
yourself and it can start it can be one
of those things that can start a
virtuous cycle occurring which is partly
why it's taught in the military get
these guys that come in there all
slumped over they don't know how to
stand up they're looking at their feet
their necks are bent like even if
they're good-looking men they don't look
good because they're all crunched over
you see people like this on the street
all the time they could be perfectly
attractive except they're completely
huddled in you know they need to stand
up and stretch themselves out and then
they can breathe too and that's a
competent stance one of the things that
the the critics of the modern West don't
understand about hierarchies is that
first of all they're everywhere they're
inevitable if you're going to have a
distinction of value between things you
have a hierarchy and if you you don't
want to get rid of the distinction of
values between things because then you
don't have anything to do that's foolish
it's you can't live that way so they say
well the hierarchies are based on power
it's like no they're not they're based
on competence and there isn't anything
more powerful than competence but power
isn't tyranny it's not brutality it's
not threat it might be the hint of all
those things you know because I don't
think you can be fully competent without
being able to hint at those things but
hierarchies in the West are
fundamentally based on competence that
doesn't mean they're not flawed because
we miss the mark lots and there's lots
of reasons why perfectly competent
people don't attain the position that
they deserve and that they should have
for their benefit and everyone else's
that the hierarchies are tainted by
corruption but fundamentally they're
fundamentally they're based on
competence and and that's so so with
that this first rule that you put into
that book and you're saying that's a
cycle that can go backwards so you don't
have to have like the serotonin first
and then you stand up if you stand up
straight you will somehow increase your
serotonin
definitely you can actually - you're
saying you say you could inject lobsters
with serotonin and they start to stand
straighter yeah you can weigh 16mm
antidepressants so like if a lobster
gets defeated in a fight then he's
statistically more likely to lose the
next fight than you would guess from a
Tele of his previous victories so that's
the first thing if you lose you increase
your risk of further loss but if you win
you increase your risk of future gains
that's that's a very important principle
it's a crucially important principle it
governs life but yeah if you take a
lobster and he gets all defeated and
he's off pouting and won't fight anymore
because he's you know having a bad day
and you inject him with serotonin
essentially give him antidepressants
it's the same thing
then he'll straighten up and he'll go
out and have another scrap it's like and
I read that oh I don't know it's
probably at least 10 years ago when I
was reading about well the the neural
physiology of these neuro chemical
systems that's why I got on to it it
just it was another thing that just blew
me away I thought really
you're kidding that circuit is that old
it's like it's that old Siri
you know that's way before there were
trees that's how long ago that is and so
hierarchy is a patriarchal construction
how about no that's wrong it's seriously
wrong so I had a mouse talking one of my
friends the other night his name is Joe
he's got a kid that's wrestling his kid
is six years old I think DOM and he says
you know he's getting put into the
higher category he's kind of getting his
but wimp now and I'm really not sure
what are you thinking I said well you
want him to win because when he wins
it's more fun and we has more fun so now
I have actual more evidence that you
should get your kids in a position again
I think your kids should get beat
sometimes yeah but they should certainly
not get beat down all the time exactly I
did that to my kids when when my kids
first started you Jitsu I put them oh
you're good you're to compete because
I'm telling you to yeah and then I'm
gonna put you in a higher weight class
with older kids because that's gonna
make you tougher if that was my you know
stupid thinking yeah and now with my
younger start I'm like no no you go on
you have fun and you go out and you
compete against people that are somewhat
equal to you maybe a little bit low you
maybe a little higher but depending on
your mood times yeah yeah well
absolutely what well that's I think we
could we can think about that
also in terms of the conversation about
meaning that we started to have it's
like if you win all the time that's
meaningless because well and you think
why because you want to win it's like
yeah fair enough so why would winning
all the time become meaningless it's
because your theory of winning isn't
sophisticated enough because here's how
you win you play the game to win but
while you're playing you play in a way
so that you get better at the game right
because you're gonna play a bunch of
games well it's even more than that you
play the game to win but you play it so
that you get better at the game
okay fine that makes sense so you want
to push yourself right because that's
how you get better and so you need
competition to push yourself so you need
to have the risk of loss because
otherwise you won't do it but here's an
even better way of thinking about it you
play the game so that you don't only get
better at that game but you get better
at the entire set of possible games and
that's what you do when you're a good
sport it's like well so how do you do
that well partly you you find the proper
level of competition right so you want
to be pushed so that you will make the
effort necessary to remove what's
useless about yourself and to help
foster the growth of what's useful and
if you do that then you get the the joy
of participating in the game towards
victory but the extra joy of building
yourself more and more strongly at the
same time and so when you tell your kid
doesn't matter whether you win or lose
it's how you play the game your kid says
what do you mean by that and you say I
don't know I don't know what I mean by
that because the kid says I'm supposed
to win our day it's like well yeah so
why does it matter how I play the game
it's like well then you're stumped even
though you're right you just don't know
why but the reason is is you want to
tell you here's the reason it's like we
can make this very simple life is not a
game it's a series of games it's
actually a series of diverse games ok so
who's the winner of this series of
diverse games because that's the real
question
right not who wins a game it's like
whatever you win a game it's like if I
hold a gun to your head and we're
playing chess I could say lose it's like
I win it's like well that's not helpful
obviously so you want to teach your kid
you want to help your kid learn to be
the winner of the set of diverse games
okay so what does that winner look like
well here's the first clue that's the
person who keeps getting invited to play
you know so because you win if people
invite you to play all the time
you have opportunities coming to you
just non-stop and maybe like let's say
you have 50 opportunities and each of
them are potentially 50% for you and 50%
for the other person you think well
that's a pretty good deal and then you
think well wait a minute let's flip this
around so it's like 60% for the other
person and 40% for me I'm gonna be like
I'm gonna go I'm gonna overboard in the
generosity you think well then what
happens well then instead of having
twenty opportunities at every moment you
have like fifty opportunities at every
moment and that's so that's what you
want for your kids is you want all the
invisible doors around them to open and
you do that by sin play nobly right pay
attention to your teammates pass the
damn puck so they get a chance right
even if you're the best player on the
team help the people on your team
develop don't grandstand right don't if
you have the opportunity to beat your
opponent 20 to 1 you know in goals it
doesn't happen very often but it can
especially when kids are playing it's
like well maybe after you're up 7 to 1
it's like back off a bit you don't have
to humiliate your opponents that's
because it's it's what would you say
it's contemptible behavior on your part
and so and you know that because you go
and watch a hockey game or something
like that and you watch a kid that
really knows how to play it's like
they're playing like mad to win they're
pushing themselves to be better but
they're paying attention to their damn
teammates and they're they respect their
opponents and you think well that's
that's a hell of a kid there it's like
yeah that's exactly right that that kids
going somewhere dude do kids ever show
they get so committed let's say hockey
right you get a kid that's just so
committed to winning and hockey that
he's gonna lose it other games well
that's that's all the games in life
right that's another
that's another problem is like you could
be over Borg yeah well well the other
thing too is that with sports like you
could say well most kids aren't gonna be
NHL level hockey players like that's
impossible
like maybe you should aim for that I
would say probably not because it's so
damn unlikely but whatever some kids are
going to manage that and more power to
them say well what are the sports for
for the rest of the kids and the answer
to that is well obviously there's the
physical discipline and the health that
goes along with that and the ability to
engage in and tolerate competition and
learn how to be a gracious winner and a
gracious loser but a lot of it is
character that all that's part of
character building that's what you want
just you say well why build your
character it's like well how how about
that's your set of toolkits for that's
your set of tools for dealing with
catastrophe how about that for a reason
right so one of the things I've
suggested to my viewers this is the men
in particular but not just the man you
should be the most reliable person at
your father's funeral that's a good goal
man that's a good goal because
everyone's broken in a situation like
that and you adding to that brokenness
and misery I mean you're gonna be
grieving like no doubt about it and and
no kidding but there's a time to step
forward with some character you know and
it's the same thing you're gonna be at
someone's deathbed you gonna be
quibbling with your siblings while
you're doing that well your parents
dying it's like it's bad enough that
they're dying that's tragedy right but
you can turn that into hell no problem
you just get a bunch of people with no
character around a deathbed and it's
like well it's bad enough but that turns
it into something like hell and that
happens in people's lives all the time
it's like character is everything so and
that's why the wise people of our past
tradition insisted upon that they say
well don't lie well why not well it
destroys your character well so what
well then you turn suffering into hell
is that what you want maybe you know cuz
people will want that but I would say
walk away from people like that right
that's not unless that's what you want
then
yeah you've got a lot of I mean it's
it's interesting as I'm since I just got
done reading the book you know I can
hear you just heating the wave drops of
all the different rules and they're all
interconnected about don't you know
don't lie or or or tell the truth or at
least don't lie yeah and then you know
Hank what's the what's the chapter about
hanging around with you can't want to
see you do well yeah yeah make friends
with people who want the best for you
right yeah it's so well it's a really
it's a real technical idea so Carl
Rogers who's a psychotherapist great
psychotherapist I'd very much recommend
his books to people especially if they
want to learn to listen because he was
really good at teaching people how to
listen he had this idea that what he
would manifest towards his clients in
therapy was unconditional positive
regard and I've always had trouble with
that because well because you don't
treat your children for example with
unconditional positive reviews there's
no matter what someone says you're
saying yeah that's a good idea well
that's that's why it's tricky well what
do you what do you he didn't articulate
it I think as well as he might have what
you want to do is for your child is that
you want the best for the best in them
that's what you want and that's what you
want from people that you surround
yourself with
now they'll hold you to a high standard
if that's the case right because
whenever you degenerate in any of the
multiple ways that you're likely to
degenerate they're gonna like whack you
on the back of the head and say you know
clue the hell in you know you're you're
demeaning yourself you're less than you
could be and there's real judgment and
then it's harsh you know but with
friends it's the same thing you want
friends they're not friends if they're
not these people you want friends who
when something good happens to you there
that's good for you right they're happy
about that they're not like all bitter
and resentful underground and like
saying horrible things behind your back
and telling you how they did something
that was better and trying to drag you
down it's like that's not helpful and
then when something bad happens to you
and you go to them and you say look this
terrible thing happened to me first of
all they don't try to top it with some
like horrible thing that happened to
them because they don't have the
patience to listen and second they're
not secretly gloating about the fact
that catastrophe finally beef
lü it's like they're actually hurt by it
and that chapters an injunction is like
take a look at the people that are
around you and if they're not on the
side of what's good for you then walk
away because well first of all that's
best for them too if you put up with
that all you're doing is enabling it
it's like well it's okay that you
mistreat me in a way that's harmful to
me and everyone else it's like actually
no that is not okay
it's not in it's not the least bit okay
that doesn't mean you shouldn't try to
help someone when they're down that's a
whole different issue what if it's your
family so you know you say like walk
away right yeah
do you still walk away from your family
or do you do if it's necessary yeah
there's lots of different ways of
walking away oh yeah don't forget that
well there's that for sure there's that
I mean you you sometimes someone's on an
encouraging path like there's just
nothing you can do you know maybe
they're a man down there a man down hard
and they're bitter and everything they
do is to produce misery virtually
everything and you have to detach
yourself from that's like I always think
about it from the perspective of a
lifeguard so if you're training to be a
lifeguard one of the things that you're
trained to do is to approach someone
who's drowning and panicking and the way
you approach them is you put your foot
out between you and them and you push
forward with your hands with your foot
out and you basically tell them if
they're flailing about you say look I'm
here to help but you have to calm down
and then if they cling to you like in
panic you push them away you think well
that's pretty damn cruel because what if
they drown it's like yeah what if you
both drowned that's like not helpful
you're you're there to rescue them they
take you down you're both dead
it's like fail right so you say look
good panicking I'll help you out
but I'm not drowning along with you it's
like well it's the same with someone in
your family it's like if they're on a
downward path and you've done your best
you know you've made your efforts you've
and they're not paying attention they're
not changing they say yeah well I'll
quit doing this yeah I'll quit doing
this they tell you the same story over
and over and over it's a downhill path
you don't trust it at some point first
of all you stop
offering your words that's do not cast
pearls before swine a very very harsh
statement right but what it means is if
someone if you're offering words of
wisdom to someone in the genuine attempt
help and they treat that with contempt
then shut up because you're demeaning
your words by throwing them away you
think well how do you help someone who's
aiming down
well sometimes you help them by walking
away and saying look you're aiming down
so hard that I am the spite the fact
you're my brother man it's like you know
this is killing me you're aiming down so
hard I'm not coming along with you and
the reason I'm not is to tell you in no
uncertain terms that what you're doing
is so terrible that I will even violate
our kinship to oppose it and maybe it'll
take them 10 years to wake up to that
you know and something that can be the
case because you know people often have
to be hit so many times before they'll
learn you see that especially if
someone's addicted or or otherwise
pursuing a pathway that's like seriously
downhill so yeah you are you put you
cover that pretty well in that chapter
where you're saying there's a certain
point where you just gotta say it up
we're done yeah we're done we're done
well it's like why should I think that
you're actually trying to change maybe
you're just telling me is you're you
tell me the story that you use to
justify your own idiocy to yourself and
then you tell it to me and you demand
that because I'm compassionate I accept
it and therefore validate your excuse
it's like well that like it's really
hard not to get tangled up in that right
because if someone who's really in rough
shape is telling you about why they're
suffering first of all they're probably
about half right in their story but some
of its justification and excuse and
blaming and all of that failure to take
responsibility it's really hard to stand
up and say no I don't buy that no I
don't buy that no you're wrong about
that you have to be a brutal bastard in
order to do that but hey sometimes like
surgery is brutal right it's brutal but
they're allowed to cut you open and
we're gonna rip out part of your body
however
right right exactly right precisely and
so so this chapter about you know only
making friends with people who want the
best for you that's a brutal chapter you
know but it's right unfortunately going
to your book a little bit I'm gonna I'm
gonna pick up going back to that first
thought
standing up means voluntarily accepting
the burden of being your nervous system
responds in an entirely different manner
when you face the demands of life
voluntarily you respond to a challenge
instead of bracing for a catastrophe you
see the gold the dragon hordes instead
of shrinking and terror from the
all-too-real fact of the Dragon you step
forward to take your place in the
dominance hierarchy and occupy your
territory manifesting your willingness
to defend expand and transform it to
stand up straight with your shoulders
back is to accept the terrible
responsibilities of life with eyes wide
open okay the reason I pulled that one
out in particular is the feeling that
you have as a soldier or as a military
person the feeling that you have going
on an offensive operation where let's
say you're a bad guy and I'm gonna come
and get you all right well first of all
you don't know and I'm sneaking up on
you and I have all this power right I I
feel good about it I'm going to get you
the opposite of that is when I'm doing a
convoy or I'm going on a patrol where
now the bad guys are out there they're
waiting to attack me and that is a
defensive posture and your attitude
about that type of thing is bad now we
were trained our guys that we made a
specific point with my guys I would say
look when you're on patrol we're on
offense we are scanning we are looking
to get the to get us to be standing up
straight and to get the mentality of we
want to do this and we're moving towards
the target as opposed to we're being
chased that's a big deal it absolutely
that's a big deal
yeah and that's that's what would you
say that's an extreme example of what's
necessary under normal conditions in
life so what
one of the things that happens if you're
treating someone who has a phobia say
like agoraphobic so they become afraid
of virtually everything maybe they're
afraid of an elevator it's one of many
fears and so you think well and they're
afraid of an elevator because they've
actually gone in elevators and have
panic attacks so it's weird because what
you do to cure them is to get them to go
in elevators and you think well wait a
second that's actually what caused the
problem so how can getting them to do
that again make it better and the answer
is because they've gone in elevators
their whole life right didn't yet they
still become terrified so how can
getting them to go on an elevator cure
them for a long time people thought well
you get them to relax while they were in
the elevator and the pairing of the
relaxation with being in the elevator
taught them to not be afraid that was
the first theory but then people learned
that no you could just get them to go in
the elevator
without having them relaxed and it also
worked and eventually psychologists
sorted this out and what they figured
out was that voluntarily encountering
something you're afraid of is not the
same thing as running from it like it's
seriously not the same thing so you say
to the person okay you're afraid of the
elevator let's can you go look at an
elevator they usually say yes and maybe
they're so terrified because they're so
far gone in their illness that they
can't say well how about we look at a
bunch of pictures of elevators since
like virtually everyone can do that
so say let's look at pictures of
elevators till you're bored that
actually doesn't take very long it's
actually quite boring so then the next
thing would be well let's go you have to
have the person trust you and so the
rule is look we're gonna do some things
that are gonna push you like competition
right but you can stop whenever you want
and we're not gonna push you any farther
than is good for you and I'll stop
anytime you want I often practice with
my clients like I taught one client
awhile back to not be afraid of needles
and he was afraid of needles and I'll
tell you what that meant he had dental
surgery with no anesthesia right okay so
that gives you some level of what it's
like to be afraid it's like all do the
dental surgery but you're not putting
that needle in there it's really it's
like I'm no needles so so I taught him
how to not be afraid of needles you know
and it didn't take very long but the
first thing I did said I told him I was
gonna bring a needle into the office and
that was all I told him the first week
is next week I'm
bring a needle in here and I'm gonna
keep it sheathed and it's gonna be
sitting on a shelf and that's where I'm
gonna put it and when you come in here
you can look at it and if you want me to
put it away then I'll put it away it's
under your control and then so he was ok
with that so he came in I said there's
the needle said you want to look at it
and said no it's but Kenny it's like oh
look out so he looked at it and then he
said look like I'm gonna pick up the
needle and now what you're gonna do is
you're gonna tell me to put it down and
I'm gonna put it down so I picked it up
he got nervous like right away and he
said will you put that down I put it
down right away I said we do that 10
times so that the bottom part of your
nervous system actually knows that
that's what's going to happen said now
and then the next thing we'll do is
we're gonna practice you saying you've
had enough and leaving the office so I
pick up the needle and he'd say okay so
now you say you've had enough I'm
leaving and so he said that and then I'd
let him leave if we did that like 10
times so that he knew that he could just
say he'd had enough and leave so that
mean he didn't have to be a prey animal
right so we were getting him out of that
moat and it didn't take very long until
well then I could bring the needle close
to him and I say make sure you watch it
you can't pretend it's not there right
I'll bring it close to him and touch it
and touch him with a sheath needle so we
did that a bunch and then finally I
unsheathed it and I'd bring it close and
he tolerate that or stopped me and then
I touch him with that and then the last
part of it was that I put it under a
piece of paper so he couldn't see it and
then I'd bring it close to him right
because that was that was the unknown
right you don't know what the hell's
going on underneath the piece of paper
but he got to the point where he could
go and have a needle I took home boat it
was very brave of him to do this because
well what had happened he got what had
happened to him is he had a very bad
experience with the childhood dentist
all the same yeah oh yeah held him did
six people held him down to give him a
needle so good it had some long-term
consequences but see what happened so
when you when you do that with people
you don't teach them to be less afraid
you teach them to be braver that's
different and so like I had a client
once the doors open on the elevator and
she looked and she said that's death
like that's a tube and I thought wow
that's an amazing response and her
she'd go in there her heart rate would
accelerate she'd have a heart attack and
she died so as far as she was concerned
walking in there was death right okay so
for me it was an elevator but for her it
was death it's like okay well what do
you do about your fear of death
well we're not getting rid of that it's
like you know and you could die in the
elevator you actually could probably you
won't but people do die in elevators and
her idea was that well if anyone has
ever died in an elevator in the history
of mankind that's a good reason for me
not to be in the elevator it's like fair
enough you know and then why aren't you
terrified of out of your skull all the
time because while you're wandering
around you might have a heart attack
like that we'll probably in fact happen
to you at some point so why aren't you
terrified of that at every moment well
that's the mystery well so you treat
people and and you see with that client
what I eventually did with hers we went
and watched an embalming she was
terrified of death like seriously yeah
yeah yeah right no kidding but you know
so you get you don't get less afraid you
get braver that's better because there's
plenty of things to be afraid of but you
can get braver say something people
manage this on their own ever oh yeah
yeah yeah people managed it on their own
they'd managed it on their own all the
time like you know let's say you're in a
ratty horrible job and you're being
oppressed by your boss and one day you
think I've had enough and you go write
your resume it's like there you go
that's what you're doing it's like you
know you're here because you think well
I've got the devil I know and and then
there's devil I don't know and that's
relevant when you're when you're trying
to switch careers can I find another job
will anyone hire me how long will this
take do I have to get educated again I
have to put my resume together that's a
real pain because there's holes in it
and I don't know how to present myself
then I have to go to interviews and it's
like oh my god that's all you know
that's a lot of trouble well then you
think no I'm gonna start that I'm gonna
rewrite my resume it's like well then
you get right is you're moving forward
in your life you're not taken being
terrorized by your son of a bitch of a
boss and you're out to do something
about it you know and people can get
really good at that so one of the things
you do as a psychotherapist is you do
assertiveness
it's like so people come and they say
help help I'm being oppressed in the
famous Monty Python in the famous Monty
Python manner and you say ok look well
first of all you're probably whining a
lot so let's figure that out so you quit
whining and then let's figure out how
you actually are oppressed and what
might be done about it and then let's
figure out a strategy and then let's
help you practice this strategy until
you get good at it and and let's also
map out the consequences of not fixing
it because people think well how can I
stand up to my boss it's like that's
terrible
I might risk my job it's like yeah fair
enough no wonder you're afraid of that
maybe you should just shut up let's see
what your life would be like in ten
years if you just shut up it's like you
know how about it is now it's like it's
gonna be way worse than that because
you're gonna shrink and shrink and
shrink and your boss is going to become
more and more tyrannical and you're
gonna hate every minute of your life and
it's like you want that Eridu you want
to confront your boss or change jobs
it's like oh I see it's like hell here
that's hell here I get it I get to pick
which of those I'm going to walk down
and that's a relief to people most of
the time it's so funny because people
often think they have their paralyzed
because they think that there's a good
option right yeah but and what are the
things you do as a psychotherapist to
say oh no you know no you're screwed no
matter which way you turn it's it's like
a crocodile here and it's a wolf there
and and behind you there's a hyena it's
like there's no Lambs you're not in lamb
territory it's all predators well pick
your battle pick your battle and then
all of a sudden you're in the battle and
then it doesn't matter that it's a hyena
because you're warrior so fine bring it
on it this is a common to another point
that I picked up from the book that I I
have a leadership and management
consulting company started work for the
companies all the time and one of the
topics has come up a bunch in the past
couple of years
is you know when you're when you're
dealing with someone you're dealing with
an employee and you've got fire um and
how this is big hard conversation and
etc etc no one wants to have those and I
always say look if you have the hard
conversation earlier it's not so hard
because all I have to tell you is hey
Jordan you know you would
today and we're not supposed to be late
and you all sorry and the problems you
can sorts itself out or it or it doesn't
and then I got escalate yeah but what
you talk about in the book is if there's
a problem go attack it you go get that
problem solved
don't go after that threat you know the
Dragons in there go get it well your
observation is dead-on it's like and
this is the problem with being too nice
like I don't what regard nice as a
virtue or if it's a virtue it's a very
low order virtue because what nice
usually means but nice usually means is
I don't want to cause conflict now even
though the consequences of the conflict
might multiply into the future so let's
say you have an employee that's
chronically late right and but you I
don't want to I don't really want to
disturb them I don't want to cause any
trouble it's like well you're angry
about it cuz they're late and they're
not supposed to be so you're getting all
bitter and resentful plus you're not
doing them any favors you know because
you're also telling them that you can be
taken advantage of and that their lack
of discipline is okay and then you know
so then you're gonna dislike the
employee and you're gonna amplify their
other errors and your because of your
distaste and then and if they are
someone who's taking advantage of you
then they're gonna take advantage of you
a little more and then a little more and
then a little more and a little more and
then you're gonna have to have a really
difficult conversation or put up with it
and that might sink your business
especially if you're a small business
owner so by not confronting the dragon
when it's like two inches high and can
only you know it's like it can belch out
something like a Bic lighter you wait
until the thing can inflame the whole
room and then you say oh my god like
isn't this hellish it's like well you
knew that there was something to say you
knew it you knew it a thousand times and
now you can't just say the one thing you
have to say the thousand things or maybe
you have to say that ten thousand things
and it's just destructive in every way
so yeah that's not good now here's where
I need help with this so what I think
people might get the idea is okay if I'm
in a relationship with my wife yep she
gives serves me dry chicken again yeah
right which is a common theme in my
house but actually thanks to the
internet it's actually changed now cuz
she's gotten thousands of people that
have now sent her how to keep the
chicken moist so she does
great job but for for um you know we're
talking about two decades of my life
we're talking about dry chicken out this
is a problem it is so well you know what
I did I didn't say anything because I
just would drink more water yeah more
water at dinner yeah I I fear that
sometimes people say well you know what
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna run
around it I'm gonna tell the truth to
everyone all the time on these little
things that don't matter now my my
actual best example that have ever heard
of this we we had a guy on the podcast
named Charlie plum he was a pilot in
Vietnam he was shot down in and on his
last mission of his deployment he was
shot down he was captured he was in the
Hanoi Hilton for six years this is the
deal that they had amongst their
roommates so they had roommates in a
room smaller than we're in right now and
their before of them in there three of
them in there too from there depending
on what's going on if you did something
that normally if Jordan does something
that annoys me we got to live together
if you do something that annoys me it's
my fault
mm-hmm it's my fault for allowing you
click click click your nails together or
you pick your nose a lot or you itch
your head whatever it is that you do
that bothers me it's my problem and I
have to absorb it because otherwise what
we have is we have like rats in a cage
that are gonna gnaw each other apart
and and I thought about that while I was
reading the part of the book that was
saying like and you actually also later
in the book talked about hey you know
are you gonna get a fight over this
little stupid thing are you gonna absorb
and I talked about that a lot as a
leader yeah as a person in a
relationship
hey there's problems from your boss you
absorb them that you don't pass them
down to your people you know you you
want us to stay work and order stay late
and do a bunch of crazy stuff that we
don't think we should be doing cool my
guys are gonna go home I'm gonna absorb
that I'll get it done myself I'm not
gonna I'm gonna solve these problems now
are there some tertiary effects of
course or secondary effects that now my
boss thinks he can get away with that
and all those things but I just think
there's we have to be careful that we're
not just throwing Oh deaf ears of truth
in people so yeah well I think those are
black truths they're the opposite of
white lies right so black truths are
truths you use to hurt other people
right and so technically in the moment
the statement is factual but the context
belies it right whereas a white lie it's
like well it's a little lie but you're
trying to support a larger truth not
that white white lies aren't optimal you
know it's better not to lie but
sometimes the best you can manage is a
white lie and then make sure that's a
pretty good well okay so then in those
sorts of situations you think well first
of all I have some rules of thumb if
someone does something at work that
annoys you
it's like write it off man it's like
that's once it's like what does that
mean you're having a bad you're having a
bad day or I'm having a bad day it's
like doesn't mean anything
do it twice think it's okay let's write
that off rake that off it's that's it's
the same issue it could still just be
circumstances situation three times okay
now there might be grounds for a
conversation you go and say well you
know you put your feet up on my desk
like a day ago and that was okay but
then you did it again and then like you
did it again and I'm thinking it
actually happened three times right so
there's no denying it and perhaps that's
not optimal and then you go for the
smallest possible victory that's the
next thing is like I'm not telling you
that you're what would you say that you
lack respect or that there's something
wrong with you what I'm asking is that
if you come in my office it would be
better for both of us if your feet
stayed on the floor is that okay you
know and and that's a small thing you're
not going after the person's character
right you're going after the tiny
victory so you say to your wife look
like I'm thrilled to death that you're
cooking me dinner I'm really I'm serious
because and it could be a hell of a lot
worse than it is you know and and maybe
I could be more helpful around the
kitchen that's certainly a possibility
but I have got this thing with regards
to chicken and maybe it's me you know
but could we try for like a month to
cook it differently and then we'll
revisit it and if I happen to be wrong
like I'll shut the hell up and she might
think okay well he is kind of useless
around the kitchen and sort of bitchy
about the chicken and all of that but
maybe I trust him enough to admit that I
made a small mistake and rectify it and
we could go long and not have the damn
chicken thing hanging over our heads
till we're 80
you know you just in your second example
there you tell people this all the time
so you cut you're coming into my office
and you're putting your feet ask what
I'll generally do is make it my fault I
generally say hey Jordan I hate to be
like a nitpicker yeah but I'm really
freaked out about germs it's really
stupid but I am and when you come and
put your feet on my desk it freaks me
out
yeah you just do me a favor and not put
your foot in your name come here it's
same thing with you know with the
chicken it's like hey you know what I
have a super sensitive palate refined
and I'm sorry but and I just yeah could
we maybe figure out another way to cook
that or okay we try you know but I'll
take the blame for for the situation
rather than your you're disrespectful
don't put your feet on my desk this is
well you don't want to adopt more of a
position of moral superiority than is
absolutely necessary
one of the things I recommend I don't
remember if I wrote it in 12 rules for
life I think I did about how to let's
say you're in an intractable argument
with your wife about who's the most
reprehensible person right which is
where arguments sort of end when they go
to hell
I think now you're in one of those
arguments and you risk bringing up the
past which is a very very bad idea right
maybe you're saying something like
you've always been this way you're this
way down you'll never change and none of
it's good it's like oh man that's a
fight because what are you gonna go from
there so one of the things I recommend
and this actually works is when you're
in one of these battles and you can't
bloody well get out of it you separate
each go to your room and you sit and
think okay that person is really wrong
and I'd like to give them a good
stomping and but then you think no I go
to live with them so that's probably not
a good idea right because I don't want
to live with someone who's like stomped
and angry about it because they're gonna
take their revenge like if they have any
spirit at all so you cannot win an
argument with your wife that's just
wrong you can't you can make peace you
can come up with a solution but if you
win she loses and then she's the loser
and like unless you want
have a loser around that's not a very
good strategy anyway so you go to your
room and you think okay fundamentally
flawed as my wife is particularly in
this particular circumstance there's
probably something stupid I did in the
relatively recent past that increase the
probability that we're in this little
hellish place and you think what was it
and you think oh god I really don't want
to know it's like I really don't want to
know this and so you think no I'm gonna
figure out where I'm 1% at fault she's
99% wrong but I'm I'm 1% at fault so you
sit there and you think okay what was it
then you let your imagination sort of
wander over your past stupidities and
you think oh there is something I did
that was like kind of underhanded and
devious and crooked and pathetic and
weasly and and then you go and you tell
her and she does the same thing yeah you
know and she's just as irritated about
it as you are and then you think okay
and you say look I'm sorry about that
and I know this increased the
probability that we're in this like
bitchy horrible place she does the same
thing and then you think oh yeah well
we're both pathetic losers and we can
quit plan like dominance hierarchy and
then maybe you can have a conversation
about how to make it better and that
conversation should be bounded too it's
like the chicken thing is a really good
my father-in-law who I really like he
used to come my wife told me this story
he used to come home for lunch and his
wife would feed him lunch and she always
used little plates and it was like
they'd be married for 30 years and one
day had this explosion at the table
about the fact that he'd he'd had to eat
off these damn little plates for 30
years and you know it was much more of a
large explosion than it had to be but
it's these little things actually matter
they they actually matter you have to
straighten them out because your life
especially with your wife is composed of
about fifty little things that you do
every day
and because you do them every day
they're not little you can just do the
arithmetic you know it's like maybe you
don't like the way your wife greets you
when you come home it's like okay is
that relevant is that important well
let's say it takes ten minutes because
you're thinking about it you're coming
home and then there's the little
aftermath it's ten minutes so it's like
an hour a week
it's four hours a month it's 50 hours a
year that's one workweek it's 2% of your
life
it's like 2% of your life right so
that's the math it's like if you got 50
of those things right your whole life
would be right think is it worth
fighting about it's like yeah it's worth
it because it's 2% of your life what's
one percent even whatever and then you
think okay well how should people greet
themselves when they first come home
it's like well maybe it's not quite like
your dog greets you because your dog is
like reprehensibly happy to see you
that's just too much right little kid
will do that but maybe you want the
person to not be watching TV for the
second you entered the house maybe they
should just stop watching TV and come
and say you know hello how was your day
and give you a hug that would be a good
thing and then maybe you do the same
thing to them and you practice that for
like two months because you're both
stupid and it's really hard for you to
learn anything and then you've got that
down and that the dinner times are like
that too like lot and lots of households
meal times are really fractured which is
a bad thing or they're bitter it's like
I'm here's your goddamn food that's like
yeah I'll eat it but I can't stand it
and you can't cook it's like okay that's
four and a half hours a day right for
your whole life you think you're gonna
like someone like that not a bit man
you're not gonna like them so you fix
that you actually do did tell that whole
thing in the book so that's it's good as
in there and actually the phrasing that
you used when you say if you win an
argument you said something along the
lines of you win you win that argument
they're the loser yeah now you win that
argument a hundred times now in a
marriage you win ten thousand times and
you are now married to a loser and that
loser that loser is not going to be
someone who makes any effort whatsoever
ever to be attractive to you or anyone
else then you'll think oh look look look
look who I ended up with it's like no
look at how you produced it's like good
work there guy and and that's the that's
the so so what you're talking about with
this argument thing and you look go but
you separate you go in your room you say
okay what did I do wrong
Yeah right I do wrong that's annoying
what did I do wrong and and
interestingly myself and my buddy Leif
babban we wrote
called extreme ownership and the whole
premises you take responsibility for
when things go wrong you say yeah this
was my fault so I'll go to clients and
I'll be meeting with them and I'll say
you look when your something goes wrong
with your team here with me you guys
made a mistake you fail whatever you're
trying to accomplish you know you got to
take ownership over you stand up and you
say hey look this was my fault
and this is what you know we're gonna do
and the people will say well you know
what if I did that my team is so bad
yeah that if I did that with my team you
know what they'd say they'd say you're
right it is your fault and I mean look
at me like well look so your plan Jaakko
sucks
because if I say this is my fault my
team is gonna look at me and say you're
right it is your fault and then what do
I do and right I kind of get a little
bit maybe a little bit frustrated
because I look at them and I say that's
the whole point it actually is your
fault
you're not just saying it to get out of
the the problem you're not just saying
it to make excuses for everything that's
happening no when you say hey this is my
fault that we got in this argument and
then your and your wife says yeah it is
you don't say no they say I know and you
know you have to mean where it is you
say I know and this is what I'm gonna do
to fix it and if you're a leader you say
it's my fault and your team says yeah
you're right it is your fault you say I
know that's what I just said and here's
one we do to fix it so when you take
ownership of a problem it doesn't
necessarily make the problem go away in
fact it doesn't do that at all once you
admit what the problem isn't you take
ownership of the problem then you have
to say here's what I'm gonna do to fix
it here's my linh saying let's say
you're a high school kid and you've got
a tyrant as a teacher it's like well you
could it could be the case that you have
a tyrant as a teacher and the tyrant is
particularly on your case and you think
well yeah that's an awful thing and this
person really is a tire and it's like
yeah but you're not very good at dealing
with tyrants and you might think well I
shouldn't have to be it's like fair
enough man because who wants tyrants but
the truth of the matter is is that there
is always tyranny and if you don't know
how to deal with it if you don't know
how to thrive in the face of tyranny
even then there is something wrong with
you now doesn't mean that there isn't
something wrong with the tyrant it's
like that self-evident but it does mean
that you are
who you could be because if you were
everything you could be you could manage
that situation and it might be you'd
figure out an exit strategy I mean who
the hell knows what the solution would
be but if you if you are conceiving
yourself as helpless victim then that's
what you are and I'm not saying that
there aren't situations that people find
themselves in where there's very well
it's hard to say you know that there's
very little you can do I mean that Gert
woman that we talked about earlier she
was in a pretty damn hopeless situation
and she found something she could do you
know and I've read these books Victor
Frankel's man's search for meaning and
Solzhenitsyn's Gulag Archipelago I mean
he saw people in some pretty damn dire
straits and like really really beyond
comprehension and he noticed even in
those situations that people still have
their choices to make you know and I
mean you tread on that ground with
extreme hesitancy because you don't say
well man if I was thrown in the gulag I
would have been Noble it's like no
probably not man you would have been a
trustee in about 15 minutes you know
that's the most likely outcome so you
have to be careful about not getting too
high on your horse about such things but
it isn't obvious when you're out of
choices most of the time you have more
choices you haven't used all the choices
you have most of the time now I've seen
people in situations I couldn't help
them get out of so and people died right
I mean you have a fatal illness you have
pancreatic cancer like your dad in six
months your choices are limited but
maybe under those circumstances you
figure out how to put your house in
order and be what you can to the people
who will be left it's something like
that from for me and I get a lot of that
I know you get infinitely more than me
but I'll get someone that reports to me
a problem or a situation that they're in
that seems really bad and and what I've
found is the the solution that they're
looking for the only solution that they
can conceive of is one that is going to
provide that solution within a two week
time frame like that's what we're
talking about if I'm not saw if this
problem isn't solved in two weeks
then you know this is health and I
always kind of report back and say
hey you're here in a job right now that
I understand it's bad I understand it's
your boss is terrible the team is
terrible but whatever the case is with
it or you're in a situation or your
family is this or whatever so conceive a
plan right now and it's not gonna take
two weeks it might take six months it
might take a year it might take a year
and a half of you saving your money oh
yeah and setting your resume and getting
this other skills that you need if you
can if you can extend your time and I'll
tell you what when you when you come up
with that plan when you conceive of that
plan immediately you have hope and when
you have hope you can continue on
through the miserable existence that
you're in because you know that you're
gonna you've got a plan and you're gonna
get your way out of it absolutely well I
had a client recently because I've done
a lot of consulting as well it's
clinical work and often my clients come
to me they're high functioning people
they have decent jobs but you know we
make a plan it's like well I'm making
$75,000 a year right now if the person
says I said well how much well okay
we're gonna we're gonna prove that like
why don't we see if we can triple out
see if we can triple it it's like what
the hell you know maybe we can't but
maybe we can some people do make triple
that could be you okay so what's wrong
with you well you know you're not
educated enough all right so we need to
fix that your resume isn't in order
you're not sending the damn thing out
it's like well then you got to do
baseline statistics it's like well how
many times do you have to send out your
resume to move ahead when you're already
in a pretty decent job well the answer
isn't ten the answer is like you have to
send out five a day every day for the
next two years and the the rejection
rate will be so close to a hundred
percent that that's what it will feel
like right but it's a lottery ticket you
only have to win once so it doesn't
matter if you if you lose 300 times
doesn't matter you just need one hit so
now you got to prepare yourself because
it's gonna be brutal because you're
sending out all these you know resumes
to jobs you're not quite qualified
enough for cuz you're looking to move up
brace yourself
right it's gonna be nothing but failure
nothing but failure well in this
particular client I think it took her
two years maybe more two and a half
years of sending out resumes and
accelerating her education and and
practicing because she'd get an
interview now and then and get very
close to it to get that first move right
but then she got two more in the next
year and she was out triple or celery
but you know it's like long-term
strategic thinking followed by an
implementable plan and then the
willingness to tolerate an insane run of
ridiculous failures before you move but
I've seen that happen to people there's
no reason that you can't move you just
have to figure out where you want to
move you have to figure out what the
criteria are for putting you in that
position and then you have to be some
measure of insanely persistent because
it's so unlikely right that the default
answer to the question can I have this
good job is are you out of your mind of
course not it is it's like and even if
you're qualified it's like yeah you and
ten other people so there's even an
element of chance at it especially at
the end you know like if you're in the
top five you've done everything you can
can do to control that outcome there's
some element of chance that's going to
be the determining variable because you
know maybe I don't know maybe they
didn't like the way your suit looked on
you and that's the only thing that's
differentiating you from the other
candidate it's like you also don't want
to take that too personally it's like
well you hit the top five you were
shortlisted you're in there man you're
in there you're in the game do that ten
times you'll win one of those contests
but you got to do it ten times so and
you know even in lower end jobs like
I've walked I've worked in lots of lower
end job we talked about dishwasher she
asked I'm you dishwasher exactly were
you and ice Sheriff a strong case yeah
yeah yeah well you know I was dishwasher
for a while but then that was a
short-order cook and you know but more
than that more importantly than that
even while I was a dishwasher washer
once I kind of got the hang of it which
was a lot harder than you might think
once I got the hang of it I was valued
member of that team it's like well your
dishwasher it's like yeah that's one way
of looking at it another way of looking
at is that I'm valued member of this
team and that was actually fun like I
was just a kid you know as
14 and I was I did my job properly and I
got treated like an adult it was like I
loved that I loved that that was great
and so the fact that I was well are you
a dishwasher are you a 14 year old adult
hey I'm a 14 year old adult hey I win I
win that dishwasher no dishwasher it's
like that's a good game and I really did
like that I mean when I look back in my
mid adolescence it's certainly the case
that the the times that were the best
for me was when I was working in
restaurants because I was I was part of
the team man
so you one of the sections in the book
you talk about I believe the person's
name was lunch box lunch bucket right
you know since we're talking about work
environments and there's that certain
level of camaraderie you actually talk
about the SEAL Teams in here yeah where
you just have this it's like a non I've
talked about this before in the SEAL
Teams it's nonstop a hyper verbal abuse
aggression around the clock 24 hours day
you're in a seal platoon like that's
that's life if any any mistake that you
make any any display of weakness is
gonna be professional weariness apart
you ripped apart and then if you get all
irritated about that it's the nicknames
you talked about lunch bucket your
nickname was Maui Howdy Doody and then
again - howdy which was which doesn't
felt pretty good about was better yeah
zoom from Howdy Doody which is kind of
is so good howdy which is kind of cool
right isn't Western yeah yeah but but
the nicknames that would that that are
in the SEAL Teams like I can't with good
conscience repeat them I'm sure because
they're just they're just horrible yeah
horrible names but there's a camaraderie
around that and there's also though as I
was reading what you had written about
these guys working on a rail ray where a
crew yeah there's a test it's a test
it's a test to see where you're at it's
right you made us can we rely on you can
you can you tolerate a little bit of
irritation the answer that is no it's
like well maybe we don't want you around
then because some irritating things are
likely to come down the pipe
yeah and it's it's not just it to me to
me it proves if you've got someone that
can take it right it's not just that
they can take some random joking insults
like they can they can take it they can
take it yeah that's what you're testing
for it's like can you take it lunch
bucket couldn't write because people
would laugh at his lunch bucket and he'd
get all upset it's like well you have a
stupid lunch pocket it's like you know
your mum packed it how about it you
laugh at yourself yeah my mom packed
this I know it's kind of stupid that
would have been the end of it he would
just have to say that yeah it's like but
I didn't want to hurt her feelings it's
like oh okay you know fine you got your
stupid lunch bucket but no he couldn't
handle that you know so yeah it was it
was horrible and comical to watch at the
same time because the level of and
people have written me about that they
said oh you know poor lunch bucket it's
like because they're all compassionate I
think no no not poor lunch bucket it's
like clue the hell in buddy you have
your chance you know that was a
desirable job that rail crew job in the
summer because it was high-paying you
know and they weren't easy to come by
those jobs and so the fact that he got
hired onto that crew is a real
opportunity for him you could make a
pile of money in the summer out working
on the rail crew and all you had to do
was take some ribbing with good grace
not suck up to the management too badly
and not have other people do your job
that was all that was all you had to do
but he couldn't do that and so he got
run off and it was like grow the hell up
buddy you know these guys or when a
hundred people are teasing you then
probably they're not wrong yeah when you
are getting keys like that as well well
when you when you when you stop reacting
it's no longer fun yeah yeah yeah it
also gives you an opportunity to tease
back it's like you can show your wit and
one of the things that working-class
guys in particular which is what one of
the things I really loved about working
class jobs is they're they're always
looking for some humor so it's like if
if person a is teasing person B that's
kind of comical but if person B comes
back with a good comeback it's like
that's even better you know so I think
that's a lot of how those jobs are
rendered tolerable right it's they're
they're hard dirty jobs
dishwashers a good example that's not
dangerous although cooking is
you know you gotta watch your step I got
burned a lot when I was cooking but what
makes those jobs not only tolerable but
even desirable is that you can develop a
tremendous amount of camaraderie around
them I've never really experienced that
at a professional level job that just
doesn't happen the same way and it's
really if there's a real loss in that so
it's it's it's fun to be part of a team
that's doing you know grubby hands on
things and and having a ridiculously
entertaining vicious cruel and evil time
while you're doing it that's very
entertaining the this new kids book I
wrote so the kid mark he's getting made
fun of by this he's a different kind of
bully he's like a mental belief that
that verbally abuses people and he gets
called plate face by this character and
to it eventually gets in trouble for
throwing something at the kid because
he's calling him plate face plate but
eventually way he befriends the kid is
by he they have to do a self-portrait
class knee draws a picture of himself
looking like a plate and he shows up
again the kid laughs and all sudden
they're buddies and it's like that's
what you do you take away that you take
away the joy of of being so heated and
irritated by people that are making fun
of you and you just kill it right you
Jitsu in some sense well I had an
experience with that about three years
ago
I'd put my videos up online and people
kept saying that I sounded like Kermit
well one person said it and I thought
well whatever but then like five people
said it and I thought oh my god like
this Kermit thing so then I went and
listened to Kermit I thought it's like
really I really sound like Kermit you
know and so then well then I started to
play with it a little bit you know I
used the puppet mm-hmm when I when I
went to speak to university students and
I made frog jokes and then I made a vid
I'm in a couple of videos that sort of
featured me as a frog and a means crazy
right it's ridiculous but but that's and
but but the teasing never got mean
because of that you know and the same
things happened online to a large degree
as people keep making memes of me like
and there's I don't know there's lots of
them there's way too many to even keep
track of and I was watching that happen
and I thought
this is a good thing because there's
humor and wherever there's humor that's
a good thing and they're making fun of
me but it's gentle you know most of it
was pokey you know like well you sound
like this damn puppet what do you think
of that it's like well if I had to pick
someone to sound like probably wouldn't
be a puppet but if it had to be a puppet
Kermit's not a bad one it could be a lot
worse like it could be miss Peggy I
could have been that you know so thank
God that didn't happen but the memes
have never got vicious because you know
I'll post them if they're funny and
satirical and then they won't get
vicious because they don't have to it's
like can we poke fun at you it's like
yeah please do and what the more the
better really because that'll also help
keep my feet on the ground and keep me
awake and plus it's funny and like one
of the things about life is that a sense
of humor that's a good thing to to arm
yourself with because sometimes you just
don't have anything other than that like
my daughter when she recounts her the
horrors of her adolescence she she had
to have her hip and her ankle replaced
because they both deteriorated beyond
repair beyond the possibility of repair
and she was like an agony for literally
four years it was just awful
she can tell that story in a way that
will just make you die of laughter
that's like well thank God for that
because what else do you have in a
situation like that man if you give and
sometimes it's so dark that your sense
of humor is just about gone and then
you're in real trouble but lots of times
that's what you've got against the
slings and arrows of outrageous fortune
it's like you see this with people
especially people who've been through
really hard times and they were witty
like things will be bleak bleak bleak
and they'll crack a joke and you think
well thank God man you could pop up
above that and see above it a bit and
and like you know tap it with a bit of
irony and thank God for that so when the
comedian's start to get silence there's
real trouble and that's been happening
to some degree in Canada you know
comedians are increasingly not willing
to go speak on University campuses a and
that's when the comedian's can't talk
that's a really bad sign because that's
the that comedies that's the triumph of
the human spirit over adversity right
that's why guys in these horrible jobs
are often so unbelievably funny it's
like well what else do they have you
know and actually that's a lot to be
funny like
that did that can that can move you
through a lot of dismal so you know I
I'm paying attention to time because I
know in case someone can't tell us that
we're buying an airport right now but to
kind of bring this a little bit too
close first of all we didn't cover
anything that I wanted to cover today so
we should all know that so you're coming
back with my talks like oh that's not
the talk I plan well yeah your first
biblical talk you get the first line of
Genesis right and made it one line deep
in Jonah powers well done well yeah but
one of the things in and I think it's a
good note to end on at least a little
bit to touch on because you're kind of
talking about it right now is you know
the last rule is to to pet a cat when
you encounter one on the street
it's basically find a little bit of joy
in these common things that well it's
it's a chapter about about my daughter's
experience and like it was brutal man it
was brutal she was literally walking
around on two broken legs for two years
and she had to take incredibly high
doses of opiates and so had all the
problems that went along with out she
had to take ritalin to stay awake it's
like and she was in all likelihood she
was dying there's a bunch of reasons for
that and and those were just some of her
health problems so those weren't even
the worst ones
strangely enough so it was bloody brutal
man and one of the things we told her
and we managed this thank God as I told
her once the disease started to develop
she had rheumatoid arthritis very very
seriously I said to her when she was a
little kid he said look kid this is
gonna be rough man this is gonna be
rough and and here's what you could do
to make it worse
it's like use your illness as an excuse
you do that at your peril you do that a
hundred times you will not be able to
tell the difference between suffering
that stops you from moving forward and
an excuse for not living and you'll be
done it said never never never use your
illness as an excuse like if you can't
do it you can't do it you know we have a
good experience with that it's written
in the book when we bought her a scooter
because she couldn't use public
transportation and we were all freaked
out about that because like well she has
damaged bones and you know a broken hip
and all of this like you're gonna buy
that kid a scooter really so
well what are you gonna do keep her in
her bedroom he won't think that's a good
idea tell her she can't go up in the
world
it's like have the damn scooter so after
a while she had to get a license for it
there's a licensing procedure and to do
that she actually had to write a motor
bike and so she trained to ride the
motorbike like not very long after she
had her hip replaced I think it was a
six week something like that it's of
course we're all freaked out about that
too because it's like oh man she has to
ride a motorbike and she has this hip
and it's like what are we gonna do and
she went she did the motorcycle that
first one but she dropped the bike a
couple of times and some kid wiped out
and rolled like 30 feet not kind of
freaked her out
unsurprisingly and and this so then the
second day she went with her mom to do
the motorcycle training she also got
trained to ride a motorcycle and the
second day she woke up and she said I
don't think I can do this and we thought
well you know that's understandable it's
like I can understand that and we talked
through it we said look here's what to
do man is like yeah you can't do it we
understand why you're afraid of it you
can't hold the bike up that well but why
don't you just go like go in the car
with your mom and see how you feel when
you get there because you'll get close
you get right up to it maybe you can say
no and you have to sit in the car and
like that's life and and we get it but
maybe you don't have to and she went
there so she thought that was okay and
she went there and she picked up the
damn motorbike and got her license and
everybody cheered at the end and then
she could drive her goddamn scooter
around and thank God for that because
you know she used to go out there and
she put on her helmet and she'd go on
her scooter and she was like ready to go
over the world and so that's like that's
the difference between making your kids
safe and making them strong and it was
touch and bloody go you know cuz it
could have easily been that she would
have been in a little accident with her
motorcycle and broken her leg and then
we would have thought Oh what kind of
horrible parents are we she's already
got problems and we put her on a damn
scooter in the middle of the city it's
like well you gotta be competent are you
gonna be safe it's like there's nothing
safer than competence and so and it was
great for her because it was just one
more act of courage you know and and it
and she loved that damn school
she had it for like six years and it was
a really good idea risky as hell but
really a good idea so yeah well yeah
again I'm looking at the clock we got to
get you out of here first of all twelve
rules for life an antidote to chaos
that's out right now it's number one on
Amazon in America UK Canada everywhere
that's pretty awesome I'm I'm I'm yeah
struck wordless by it yeah yeah everyone
should just get it and because we didn't
talk about anything I wanted to talk
about today you you come back we'll do
this book and everyone likes to read the
books if I can if I can before I do the
podcast so this again everyone a chance
to read it which will be awesome
any other things well I should say I've
got this online program called self
authoring and I'm offering your viewers
a and listeners a 20% discount that
helps you write out an autobiography so
you can figure out like what you haven't
sorted out about your life it helps you
write an analysis of your virtues and
faults so you can rectify the faults and
capitalize on the virtues and helps you
make a plan for the future and I would
say to your listeners don't be afraid to
do it badly because a bad plan a bad
account for yourself and a bad plan is
way better than no account for yourself
and no plan it's way better
so do it do it badly it'll it'll help
orient you in your life and we have a
preponderance of of scientific data
showing for example that people who've
done the future authoring portion of
this that's the plan are like 30 percent
more likely to stay in university it has
an overwhelming effect and it works best
on people who are doing worst which is
really quite cool so there's that I have
a personality test at understand myself
calm and you can go there and get a
analysis of ten aspects of your
personality it's kind of a harsh test
like it'll tell you actually what you're
like and it'll probably make you angry
you know because maybe not but it
probably will but it'll tell you
it'll help you figure out what jobs you
might be suited for but it'll also tell
you where you're weak and could be
stronger and so that's bitter medicine
but but it's better to know it's better
to know because then you can do
something about it so I would say those
are two useful things and and I'd
encourage people to they're inexpensive
give them a try
they'll they're helpful and on top of
that you've got your podcast yep
you've got your YouTube channel which
has hundreds of hours worth of lectures
yeah and is fantastic
Jordan Peterson calm as well and well I
just wanted to thank you for coming on
the podcast again but more important I
want to thank you for continuing to do
what you do
I know it's hard work and I know it's
taxing on you and on your family life
and all that yeah it beats suffering
stupidly it does and I know for a fact
that you're having an incredibly
positive impact all over the world
getting people everywhere to try to it
and grow the hell I grow the hell up
grow up to see that the truth yeah make
themselves and make thereby the world a
better place wouldn't that be good it
could be a better place that would be
good if we could manage that yeah indeed
all right thanks for coming on Ben well
we have excused dr. Jordan Peterson from
the this is a recording studio no we're
in a rented office a makeshift makeshift
Jordan had to go catch a plane and
continue to get out there and make the
world a better place good for him
yes good for us and Eko speaking of
making the world a better place
sure maybe you can let us know how we
might be able to make our world a little
bit better sure of course yeah first
thing we can do is stay on the path and
part of stayin on the path is
maintaining our physical capability and
competent copy competency competency is
it competence or
isn't in C competency we're gonna
maintain that that's all we're going to
do on the path so we had chocolate
supplements obviously we already know if
you don't know krill oil joint warfare
so Jaco super krill oil that's a krill
oil supplement so joint where warfare is
the glucosamine chondroitin and curcumin
yes very good things for your joints um
we you know at some point we'll go
through everything that's in there yeah
not today
yeah I will do something so that because
I won't sit here and talk about but it's
good yeah it's good use it yeah use it
the and it's not the kind where it's
good because it's generally healthy to
take these things which it is but that's
not the main push in my opinion check
the main thing is that if your joints
are kind of kind of off just like sore
dude you just do a lot do anything
breath you if you do brick laying what
does that Mason Mason if you're yeah
like just from you know back elbows and
then you start taking this you'll see
that you'll feel that a difference
specifically yeah and it's generally
healthy anyway maintain the joints
maintain the competency of your joints
with jockle
super krill join warfare take them every
day that's what I do in the routine also
discipline pre-workout it's a
pre-workout for me it's it's a pre
mission for me it's a pre mission free
trade up production cognitive yeah
enhancer yeah
and I'll tell you the only downfall of
it right now
well there's a couple number one a taste
delicious so you want to drink a lot of
it number the other day on the other day
I drank a lot of it I'm gonna have to go
and give a speech yeah I had to use the
restroom right before I went on stage
which I don't like yes be careful well
that's a general thing I know it doesn't
have to be chuckle disciplined you can
do that with water careful yeah yeah you
want to be careful didn't you eat some
of it like oh can we ate
today's see I'm trying to avoid that
yeah yeah yeah see just took a mouth a
little scoop yeah and it's not too bad
in fact you know what
you know you get like a shot of some
really nasty alcohol if you ever do it
sure but it gives you like a little hook
yeah sure for that yeah when you take
just when you eat the straight powder
sure which I'm now doing apparently it
gives you a little bit it gives you a
little not only you get the the effects
of what's in it but you need a little
bit of the mainline yeah deal yeah
that's kind of like yeah when you're kid
you buy the little kool-aid you know
when you before you make the kool-aid
you get like a little you try that stuff
straight yeah I know what it's like only
it's not quite as horrible as that I'm
better than that it's better than cool
you know good chocolate it tastes good
he's into the taste good stuff anyway
it's called did JA this it's called
discipline called rate up yeah you see
it anyway get at origin main dot-com and
also at origin mean calm you get you
that's where you can get your geek so
you don't have to along you can still
ask me what gear you get no don't ask
anymore not ask good I'll tell you no
tell you this is what I'll tell you go
to origin pick Iggy from there whichever
one you want
plenty color they're not planting colors
but the legit you have white I have one
blue G that I never used all I have is
white I'm a black key someone gave me a
black Ian isn't cool but I've never used
it but cuz a lot of people ask me that -
what color should I get yeah what color
should you get I am very traditional and
I use the white key but I do have a def
key that's black yeah but some schools
they don't even allow other colors than
white and blue yeah that's true but Pete
says black is the is the number one
seller okay like if just all colors
black now can you compete IBJJF with a
black guy I don't know I never forget
but here's what we were talking about
when you're a little kid and you think
about martial arts what do you want to
be the ninja you want to be a ninja yeah
now you got a 36 year old guy
twenty-eight-year-old guy and he finally
he's feeling kind of ninja if she's
doing the jujitsu yeah
and he's you take that one extra step
black key boom ninja yeah in a matter of
speaking yeah and I actually felt that
that's part of the reason why I don't
get a black key because I I kind of
wanted like not like there's a little
Ron's movie feathers
what do you mean can old Charles Bronson
movie called the mechanic yeah yeah
there's a there's a there's a scene
where the traditional karate guy is
gonna fight a guy that's got some new
tricks up his sleeve sure
and the traditional karate guy has to
get nuts on him yeah but he's in it just
a plain white key yeah yeah and Charles
Bronson - yeah so I'm just you know yeah
and in the line but strangely I mainly
stick to white because it's kind of
that's the the main like I'm not doing
too much with with the cool black one
because let's face it the black one like
I said about being a ninja and it looks
too bright it does it's really cool
and but I didn't want to roll in and be
like in they think you're cool with your
black key kind of thing you know the
thing is I think it's progressed beyond
that it's totally it's beyond that yeah
you're not you are not standing out at
all and I'm lucky now you might be if
you go to a traditional you know school
that has only white keys yeah you're
gonna stand out you coming to victory
MMA and fitness you could we weren't a
purple you no one's gonna care
yeah I was even looking sec camouflage
yeah no one cares it might be like dang
that's a cool camouflage they might they
might say that I just put chokehold on
your Daenerys yeah so there it is I
would say okay if they're saying hey
Chacko echo what G should I get what
color should I get
we know origin what color should I get a
ask your school first yeah cuz some they
don't allow you're gonna buy your cool
black key or there's like an army green
is there army green yeah you're gonna
buy and they looked open you're solid
you're ready to go and you come in they
say you can't train with that you can't
have that so ask your school first if
they allow all colors then owns up to
you yeah yeah but but the point is with
asking what color is that
I think that they're like hey is there
like a violation if I get this cool
black one and you answered it yet now no
no unless your school does its literally
no factor literally no fact - yeah so
they got any right origin mean calmness
we get them all so on it dot-com / Jocko
this is where I get the kettle bells the
dope kettle bells you didn't talk about
rash rash guards Oh and origin yeah yeah
and because the reason that I just
popped into my mind cuz they have spats
now because they have spats now the
first run of spats are green and like
some other color yeah yellow lying yeah
right
interesting yeah don't worry I said
Peter Jackson now I'm not a Gus bats
wearing dude no I'm not wearing tights
not happening soon no they're nothing
against people that do yeah there's some
crazy jujitsu guys out there that are
wearing tights like you read about but
as it as it ap not wearing tights yeah I
know a lot of people that do mm-hmm make
some black ones or something else yeah
these it got it you know you can get
obviously the rash guards are good to go
yeah but now you can also get spats that
are not so we're sneaking with dispatch
we're citrus bats when we figured out
the route of that's right or dope yeah
yeah it's a good thing and it's not as I
thought it would route back to you know
some ballerina yeah some ballerina think
no it's war
yeah it's what you're more in your legs
when you're up cavalrymen you know yeah
so we can say spats it's been approved
yeah it's the same thing yeah it's you
you tape you in here so we're good ankle
yeah fully interesting color choice yeah
the first one here's the thing though
yeah about the spats yeah some colors
you don't see like like if I was like
hey I'm gonna wear this lime green and
yellow thing whatever shirt spats
whatever and you'd be like lime green
yellow that just doesn't even sound good
I'm looking at these two colors I don't
think that's gonna look good but then
you put it on a shirt or spats or
something then you put it on you're like
oh dang that kind of works for some
reason I'm not saying lime green and
yellow does that I'm just saying a
certain color cut yeah come
interesting thing Pete's my bro right
sure literally with the first time I had
a Skype conversation with Pete my wife
as I could sound like you were talking
to yourself yeah we can we as a for our
conversation by the way now with that
that being said mm-hmm I wouldn't have
made spats that look like the first
Bassett II had come out with in a
million years now here's now here's the
funny thing
I can't even say I can't even say hey
Pete don't you know no one's gonna like
those you know why because my sense of
fashion
yeah is so awful yes of fashion is not
exploit its literally nothing it would
be non-existent if you even had one yeah
okay that's right well no it's
non-existent yeah if you had fun it
would be get it it's like double nothing
okay yeah well so that's why I can't
even say hey Pete I can't say I can't
make a blanket statement like Pete
people won't like those yeah I can't
even say that because I have you - no
idea
sure so I just said what I do know is
people would definitely like some black
ones right yeah that's pretty safe to
say so yeah yeah that's that I don't
mind the green oh by the way but you
even we've had this stuff we've had
issues like this yes where you make
things that I just don't yeah unapproved
nah I'm yeah there aren't approved yeah
on a proof across the board yeah but I
just know you just kind of just don't
know yeah I say okay you know I don't
know that's I gotta stay humble over
here yeah I can't claim this claim to
have any any footing to stand on at all
when it comes to fashion but as any kind
yeah and haircuts I'm pretty good with
those you know what yeah sure your head
okay next question so yeah again or
dominga calm there's a lot of cool stuff
on those hoodies and stuff too by the
way
yeah which and this is a this is a buy
not biased what'd he call it subjective
when I was wearing the full origin sweat
suit mm-hmm I don't I laid down on the
couch just took a break whatever no I
don't normally do that to look right
from what cruising you know
you know doing whatever it is I was
doing took a break
lay down on the couch full sweat suit on
origin it was the most comfortable
moment I had in recent memory and just
so everyone knows if you're talking
about
echoes comfort levels there already I
know that you know comfort and know
about it and very familiar with it and
yeah it was not saying a lot so yeah
there it is
okay back on it the kettle bells that I
get whole set
almost all set primal bells zombie bills
legend bells they're the kettle bells
that's where you get them on it calm
slash choco also they got some cool
maces on there Java is the mace right I
do yeah but yeah get me pounder you
think 20 pounds is not heavy
yeah it's heavy yeah really have that's
one of those things and we kind of
talked about it before where you wait
like wait like this many pounds or you
know kilos whatever perhaps it's not
create all created equal like if it's in
a certain form yeah or formless or
whatever that's way different like my
daughter
I forget how much deviant ways now like
53 pounds or something like that
to be puns is nothing as far as lifting
their every lift it
yeah trail lift her when she don't want
to be lifted but she's like she's a good
piece to like 150 pounds nonetheless the
point there is with these mesas and
there's all this cool stuff on there if
you want to vary up your workout make it
interesting
unlike tacos workout make it make yours
interesting if you want to do that you
don't have to there's some really good
stuff on there check them out and you
know if you want something get something
also when you get Jordan Peterson's
twelve rules just call 12 little girls
doll votes for life an antidote to chaos
Jordan B Peterson its twelve rules for
life is like it seems like a big claim
you know yeah but they're pretty they're
pretty solid pretty solid yeah
follow the song nonetheless that that is
a good one um when you get down and any
other any of the other books don't worry
I organized them all for you go to jakka
podcaster somebody said the other day on
the Internet
he said to me oh you should have a book
club we got a book club go to Jocko
podcast.com and click on books all the
books are there that's the club mate
there ya don't have to ask me about the
book club the books are there all right
yeah
ADF we gotta organize for you by episode
by the way mm little brief description
click on there boom get your book from
there it's a good way to support takes
the Amazon you can get your bookie for
you are do another shopping hain't
carry-on just do your thing no one's
gonna stop you from that of course and
that supports the podcast good way to
support small action big reaction also
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't
already that one seems obvious I know
but it's a good way to support just a
little good way to support just in right
out of you a funny review yeah I'm going
like once a week now I go and read all
the new reviews yeah ever gems yeah
there's some gems in there yeah if you
feel like it yeah so so subscribe write
a review if you want subscribe to
youtube we have a youtube channel if you
didn't know that already that's where
the video version of this podcast
resides you like that is that good job
also excerpts on there if you do I
listen or watch should I say the whole
episode or episodes got some excerpts on
there you can just watch little um you
know little excerpts little tidbits of
the podcast little ideas little lessons
tips of advice mm shorter form you know
when you take a break at work or
whatever Chuck not that you should be
watching youtube at work but if you are
you watch this boom get back to work
more effective probably probably also
some other stuff on there we're gonna
try to slowly add more and more what you
to say content not just for the sake of
adding content by the way because I make
videos from time to time
very spaced out you know they're you
know trying to get them done nonetheless
um we're gonna put more there's gonna be
more and more on there it's a new year
right what's February now Archie bro
anyway moving on also Chuck where's the
store it's called chuckle store
chocolate store calm that this is the
website online store where you can get
discipline equals freedom shirts rash
guards the victory Emma Mayen fitness
shirt The Jackal always wears like
Einstein buy though I think Einstein
wore the same thing every day too
is that what you do it no I do it cuz
it's simple not because Einstein does it
actually they say that this is the you
and Einstein wear the same thing every
day for the same reason yeah because
what they say less decision-making yeah
cuz your decision-making you know
resources yeah I don't really believe
all that I just believe I don't feel
like sitting around thinking about what
I'm gonna wear in the morning just grab
that I have a shirt drawer guess why I
said it shirts yeah now put it on right
you have bigger things to make decisions
about it think about that's exactly what
I'm saying that's what I read too so you
guys you and Einstein are like now I
don't want to say obsessed you're like
you just real into more important things
so what you wear that's that that's that
shouldn't take up too many of your
decision-making resources the thing
about chocolate or yeah I don't know if
you've ever made this clear well maybe
you have but if you want to support the
podcast that's a good way to support the
podcast for a while people want us to do
a thing where you donate money yeah and
I said well no people want to support
the we're not gonna ask for money and
give them nothing yeah we'll give them
something a t-shirt a hat a sticker yeah
good stuff by the way it's not the shirt
that makes the man it's the man that
makes this shirt so okay there you go
nonetheless there are cause you're the
one that makes these years that's it's a
different thing I think I saw it on the
movie uh
don't with Sean Connery and Catherine's
netted Catherine zeta-jones in you know
remember dad to steal something continue
okay you know what movie I'm talking
about anyway there's some hoodies on
there some hats on there
we're restocking actually I'm doing a
thing because the people email cuz you
know there's stuff out of stock in there
yeah guess what not never again I'm
hesitant to say never say never but yeah
never again okay
so everything is in stock right now not
necessarily come back when you're ready
I'm working on is all very close to
being complete okay so they'll be
available and some new stuffs gonna be
on there also rash guards on there for
jiu-jitsu or for anything physical you
know you're doing physically you want to
keep your range of motion you know
whatever anyway you know what rash
guards are I think they're pretty dope
um also women's stuff on there and I am
NOT saying I say this a lot let me say
it again not saying buy something I'm
saying go on there just look if you
don't want anything didn't don't get
something but if you do want something
get something it's a good way to sport
also that's really a deep you don't
thank you you know if you want something
get something if you don't want
something don't yeah alright cool we'll
abide by that is it kind of like you
don't like when people say it is what it
is yes chuckles not gonna be anyone but
Jocko
you know jock was jockle true right same
thing no why do you say that you know
kind of I say that for the same reason
also psychological warfare if you know
what that is it's an album with tracks
jaco tracks not Jocko playing a ukulele
or the violin or what else deeply not
really the violin I can't really play
the drums too well either
yeah but you play stuff nonetheless it's
none of that
it's Jocko to giving you cuz I'll each
track is Jacque a jock chuckles I'll
should I say tips that really tips
they're kind of tips on how to eliminate
the weakness
that you're feeling at any given moment
on your path on your campaign on the
campaign against weakness that's what it
is
so if you're about to skip your workout
because hey you don't feel like it
B you don't think you have time or
something like this or usually it's
because you don't feel like it cuz you
worked out yesterday
you're kinda sore like you were gonna do
squats today but you did a bunch of
burpees yesterday so your lower back and
your quads they're kind of sore so
you're like maybe I'll just do tomorrow
No so all you got to do it's like put in
psychological warfare listen to there's
a track for that
inhale he'll just explain just in his
own little Jocko way explain why you
shouldn't do that why you should just do
the workout and after you listen to you
be like dang that makes sense and guess
what boom all of a sudden you're doing
the workout you didn't skip it so what
you do if you like that you can also get
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
on iTunes Amazon music google play other
mp3 platforms it's not on audible it's
not on honorable it's available as an
album actually two albums also you hit
jock a white tee which as everybody now
knows will increase your deadlift to a
minimum of eight thousand pounds been
proven over and over again everyone
knows it now it's really not impressive
anymore
since so many people are hitting at
eight thousand pound max books
Jordan B Peterson maps of meaning is his
first book it's old it's big its
expensive I have it it's it's a great
read also twelve rules for life an
antidote of chaos way the warrior kid so
way the warrior kid kids book teaching
kids to how get how to get on the path
now there's a new book coming out a new
warrior kid book it is available now on
Amazon it's called way the warrior kid
marks mission it's a follow up the first
book was fifth grade the second book
sixth grade marks getting a little older
guess what
he still got some problems
and he's gonna solve them so you can
order that also as I already mentioned
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
that is available if you want to get
bigger stronger faster smarter more
disciplined better get that book and
then implement it because you can get
the book and sit and sit around and play
video games it's not gonna make you any
of those things you have to actually get
it you have to read it you have to
implement it so that works also with the
warrior kids don't forget you can get
some more your kids soap basically I got
some did you get so yeah yeah it's good
to go
Irish Oaks ranch dot-com young Aiden
who's a warrior kid making his own soap
business owner age 12 check that out
extreme ownership book by myself and my
brother lave babban it's about combat
leadership it's about how to lead that's
what it's about and people think that's
a simple thing it's not even or Jordan B
Jordan B Peterson say today leadership
is very complicated
he's right so extreme ownership will
help you in your leadership skills
tactics and strategies also if you need
leadership guidance and direction at
your company at your business or at your
team beyond what would give you here on
this podcast and beyond the books I have
a leadership and management consulting
company it's called a salon front where
we will get the leadership you have and
thereby your whole organization aligned
and moving forward together it's me it's
Lafe babban it's JP to now it's Dave
Burke you can email info at Ashkelon
front calm there you go to the website
Ashlin front calm also there is the
muster this is a leadership seminar that
hits you like an atom bomb
so the muster everyone that's been to it
there's nothing else like it the people
that work at the hotels are done that
have said there's nothing else like it
so it's awesome if you want to come to
it we're only doing two musters this
year we don't have time to do more we're
doing one in Washington DC May 17th and
18th that's for the East Coast people
May 17th and 18th Washington DC and then
we're gonna do San Francisco October
17th and 18th
that's for your West Coast people those
the only two musters that we're doing
this year we're not doing Vancouver
we're not doing Atlanta we're not doing
Memphis we're not doing Tampa those are
all great cities but we're not gonna do
a muster there we've had four monsters
already San Diego New York City San
Diego again in Austin Texas all the
monsters that we've done have sold out
these two that we're doing this year
going to sell out as well so if you want
to come registered at extreme ownership
calm we will see you there and until
then if you want to get on the path with
us you can't find us we'll be cruising
on the interwebs on Twitter on Instagram
and on - faced Ibuki bull ha the Jordan
Peterson is at Jordan B Peterson he's
also got the YouTube channel
Jordan Peterson he's got Jordan Peterson
calm echo is at Echo Charles and I am at
Jocko willing and finally thanks to all
of you I know a lot of men and women in
uniform listen to this podcast I hear
from you all the time
well we would not have this podcast if
it wasn't for you overseas holding the
line and keeping evil at bay and to the
people in uniform here at home police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
and the rest of you first responders
thank you for keeping us safe inside our
borders and to everyone else out there
moving
through life and that's good that's fine
but I recommend you don't just move
through life I recommend you move down
the path get stronger and faster and
smarter and better every day
aim to be the best and as jordan
peterson write so eloquently in his book
always place you're becoming above your
current being in other words get up and
get after it until next time this is
echo and Jocko out